so before we begin I'll take my little
poll anybody use pandas here okay
anybody have a love/hate relationship
with pandas okay so for those of you who
did not raise your hand you can leave
now so that was the joke of the day okay
today we're going to talk about the
future of pandas I'm going to describe
what we currently have and then some
possible directions where we can go
so before we start some legalese we can
read that really quickly so my name is
Jeffery back I am I've been maintaining
pandas for about about five years I
currently work at two sigma I develop
we'll call it holistic approaches to
modeling essentially I think about the
interface for modeling and how you can
interact with your data in a very
pythonic way we have lots of data we
write lots of models and we like to make
them easy to do so you all know this guy
he actually sits in the in the the room
sort of next next where I sit and so he
gets all the kudos for pandas I get all
the complaints I guess these could be
mug shots I suppose so yeah so so we're
gonna give the state of the pandas I'm
gonna talk about the good the bad and
the ugly I originally had there's a nice
Clint Eastwood film by the same name and
I had the nice video but I'd take it out
cuz you know copyright and all this so
today we kind of a little bit of a sad
pandas you know and I'll go through some
reasons for this and hopefully we can
have some happy pandas in the future
all right let's talk about the good so
this slide is actually very interesting
take
I'm not saying pandas did this was
that's the next slide this is the growth
of Python we can't all attribute this to
pandas I'm obviously the machine
learning craze you know really took off
in the early you know the 2010-11
timeframe and you know Python has really
taken a lot of mind chair and this has
you know brought a lot of folks into the
ecosystem and has really proliferated
the use cases and as a result you know
the software's become increasingly more
robust this is also another recent this
was on Twitter you know pandas now has
something like you know 1% of all Stack
Overflow questions so it begs the
question is pandas getting more popular
or my theory that there's just more bugs
and you know as you can see the pandas
actually has you know nice nice curve
there this is when I started take
managing panda okay so this is a similar
slide to what I drawn a couple of years
ago pandas is treated almost as a UI or
UX to the entire Python ecosystem for
data analysis
you know pin is a very large package it
has connectors to lots of things so you
easy to bring your data in you know Wes
used to comment that you know read CSV
basically made pandas accessible to the
world or rather made data accessible to
the data scientists who you know a few
years ago we're just called statistic as
a go-to tool you know you're in your
ipython prompt or your Jupiter notebook
and the first thing you import is pandas
to just get your data in and then of
course you can you know do lots of
manipulations and transforms and you can
you know then you know very easy to
graph things we all love matplotlib and
we all love the associated libraries in
the visual ecosystem of pandas has a lot
of built-in plotting that just works
of course we put the connectors here to
the statistics and machine learning
libraries which are of course you know
what a lot of folks really want to use
nowadays and pan is an integral part of
this you know I've seen many talks here
at PI data and you know it's all the you
know 90% preparation
you know defeat in your machine learning
model if you have bad data you have you
know bad models so all right so so I
think a lot of folks know what the good
things are pan is it makes their life
easier it does it helps them get their
work done but there's some bad things so
Wes did a post he did it a while ago but
this is an update of it I think about a
month ago so I'm not going to actually
talk about these his actual list I will
mention a number of things on it and
give my own take on this and so these
are the not all the issues but some of
the issues which are people are facing
in the current in current pandas so yes
this is a pun missing data is a problem
and I'm not gonna say that missing data
pandas handles very well the problem is
we don't handle it in a really nice way
in certain cases and I'll show you an
example in a second the other two
examples up here so one this is
essentially a dictionary or categorical
mapping this has been a problem it's a
little bit ameliorated in current pandas
but it's a problem it's not a
first-class data type and down here at
the bottom this is something that I
think a lot of folks would really want
they want units attached to the data
types themselves now we have a lot of
workarounds and a lot of ways to make
this work to some extent but it's not
built-in it's not first-class so here's
an example missing data I mean this is
the classic your energy data when you
reindex and introduced missing data
turns into float data this is unexpected
to say the least and unfortunately some
of the infrastructure that pandas built
on was designed 20 years ago
think about numpy was designed in the
early 2000s and even that has a prior
to it pandas was first came to about in
the round 2008-2009 timeframe so we're
talking over ten years ago of our
infrastructure here's some more issues
we have a fairly complex group by
semantics and I'll show you an example
in a second and we have some issues with
copying and again I'll show you an
example so when you're actually working
with data this may be an obvious problem
where so you know we have a random data
frame here a is we're going to use this
as a grouping key and a couple of values
okay so this is a standard example of D
meaning you do a group I and apply so we
form the groups we want to act on the B
column and then we're going to demean
great it's actually pretty readable here
and that's what if you know pandas
strengths of course is that things are
readable unfortunately this is very
opaque to you it's so we cannot
introspect this lambda and maybe that's
not a problem except for the fact that
when this this does not scale well okay
this is all actually executed in
equivalently of a Python for loop what
you should be doing is this this is what
I could term unwrapping group by okay
and it's the same type of transformation
but here's the rub I don't want you to
have to do that pandas should be smart
enough to figure this out there's some
limitations in the language that does
not allow us to easily figure this out
and this is where we're going to move in
the future I referred before to complex
group by semantics so a very common
operation of course is to group by and
then to aggregate potentially different
columns to different aggregators and to
even rename those okay we actually
recently removed this this capability
because you had to do addictive Dix and
this could introduce some ambiguity in
the syntax and further note that we're
using strings here to define our
aggregators it works it's fine but it
could be a lot better
everybody must love this message I threw
this in a couple of years ago and I
threw it in for a good reason - the
problem is I would get so many issues
that people would have a data frame you
assign something to it and then it
wouldn't work
I mean look what's going on so it turns
out they were assigned to something
which was actually referenced to
something else and they were doing the
to operations and it was just gone so
now at least you have a warning it's not
a great warning but if you have a
warrant so this is a problem these three
points actually do come from Wes's post
but they really boil down to a couple of
things one is pandas has essentially a
bespoke memory layout format that
underlies it and this this is the root
of a lot of issues and I'm going to show
they show you that in a second and -
it's not really designed for modern
architectures it's not really designed
to handle multi-core in a nice way so
you end up with this problem pandas is
great for we'll call it smaller data
sets five gigabytes and less if you have
really large data you've generally you
don't use pandas anyways you're using
spark or using maybe MPI you're using
some sort of cluster anyhow but there's
a large midsection of data sizes where
pandas would be very useful but you need
generally a lot of memory to deal with
pandas nowadays so say you know the
practical emmitt is say ten gigabytes
for a data set you roughly need say ten
times the amount of memory to
manipulators in a fairly easy way and
this whole this problem gets worse as
you scale this all stems from the
original design of pandas so we have
this thing called block storage and
here's just a little mini example say we
have a data frame with two data types we
have to float columns and we have one
integer column and everybody would guess
that really pandas is holding three
arrays through
one dimensional arrays but this is not
true pandas actually holds this in
two-dimensional numpy blocks and they're
grouped they're segregated by datatype
and at first you look at this in like
mmm that seems okay and it is okay for
certain applications so back in 2008
this was great actually what would
happen is you invariably took a
two-dimensional numpy array from some
aspect or system there's all floats put
it in a data frame that's extremely
cheap because we don't do anything with
it it's almost a pointer and then you
can start doing operations great we do
actually transpose so then it's actually
memory lined so actually aggregations
are pretty fast on it but in 2008 this
was probably the downside of block
storage is this if you are adding
columns you get a copy so repeatedly
adding things is bad this is why the
standard recommendation is to create
everything and then put it in all at
once furthermore this introduces these
weird copy semantics if I try to take a
column out I get a view on that column
mostly but if I then try to modify that
I can get into some very odd situations
of because we don't own the memory we're
deferring to an umpire rain sometimes
the semantics are a little bit off so
this is a problem it's worked well but
it's a problem so we talked about the
good the bad and now the ugly you've
probably seen this drawing before
there's been several other talks at this
conference about Apache Aero and the
friendliness or rather the
unfriendliness of the various formats so
the basic issue is that I'm increasingly
want to use pandas because I like its
API it's very friendly but I also want
to interact with other systems maybe
even my data stored somewhere else maybe
I want to use pandas in a multi-core way
I want to interact with spark lots of
reasons and the problem is you and
we get to a situation where you're
copying converting and constantly
serializing and deserializing data and
this is causing you know performance
issues in the present iteration of
pandas and you know we've been iterating
fairly quickly we tried a general
release a major release every six or
seven months with minor releases in
between we've actually had you know
quite an uptake of contributors I think
we have eight or nine hundred
contributors at this moment and so
there's a lot of folks who really do
care about specific edges in pandas
which is great so we've made some
strides in we'll call it making things a
little bit better for most folks so
example two miliary the ability to store
large large amounts of non numeric data
like strings so we introduced this
categorical data type now it's not the
best thing in the world it's not a
first-class data type it's not it's
actually solving two problems it's sort
of storing the memory it's solving the
memory problem of storing multiple
pieces of data and it's also acting as a
so-called factor okay it's acting as
another data type so we're using things
in a little bit loose way here recently
we added support for park' to read and
write Parque in a limited way so people
can access a a better way of storing
their data and we'll talk about this a
little bit later than talk and on the
multi-core front and the distributed
front there's a tool called desk which
I'm sure you a lot of you're familiar
with
this allows you to scale your pandas and
scale numpy and scale your computations
by paralyzing you know either locally
across multi-core or across a cluster so
there's there's hope but the real hope
is essentially a redesign of pandas and
this is actually a little bit tricky so
here's the here's the slide and I'm
going to talk through this and show you
some examples of why this makes sense
and and why this is a good idea I'll
give my standard joke you know what
the difference between a heart surgeon
and mechanic they're both in the same
thing right they're replacing the guts
but the heart surgeon case the patient's
alive right I guess it wasn't a great
show okay alright so I'm going to talk
through the stack a little bit this is
the architecture which we feel quite
confident will solve a lot of these
issues so primarily we have three
components here at the top we have a
compatibility layer we're actually gonna
talk about that last in the light blue
we're gonna talk about Ibis okay and
then we're gonna talk about apache aero
a little bit so here we go so what is
Ibis these two layers convertibles ibis
is a language for talking about what you
want to do it's an expression language
it is looks and feels very much like
pandas it feels very much like the
furred pandas for those of you work in a
we'll call it the big data feel if
you're familiar with SPARC it feels like
that you have to or if you've used desk
you have to you build up an expression
you do a series of operations that will
see them in a second and then you say do
it at the end or collect or execute okay
or compute actually for desk this is a
very powerful concept of where you're
building up your expression and then
you're doing the execution all at once
okay pandas is an eager execution engine
it doesn't do this why do we why why do
we care about Ibis or what why how is it
useful let me back up a step this
library was actually developed primarily
to translate pandas like code to run on
Impala Impala is a special sort form of
sequel engine in fact it has a very nice
property where it allows you to if
you're very explicit about your UDF's
your user-defined functions in others
the stuff that goes in the apply it will
actually compile them okay it allows you
to have a lot of control and
there forget a lot of extreme
performance it's been extended in the
the Ibis has been around a couple of
years it's been extended to actually
interact with virtually all sequel
platforms now you may be asking you've
probably heard of sequel alchemy we have
to use sequel alchemy under the hood to
address certain engines like Postgres or
sequel server or sequel light but we
also talked to other engines like
bigquery we talked to spark and the idea
here is that you write code then you can
direct where it goes where it executes
so here's an example we have a data
frame we talk to it like it's a table
like it's a sequel table and if you'll
notice this is a it's typed everything
is typed and this is the key to the
power here we know a priori all the
types we know the operations on those
yield what they what they yield what
types they yield so in this case we have
a little pandas table it has a timestamp
it has an in 64 column and it has a
string column now I say execute I get
back a data frame so so far that's not
exciting but what we've just done is we
said hey I built up an expression in
this case it's just simply a data frame
it's simply a table and now I want to
get the result here's where it becomes
interesting this is a very simple
computation I am taking I'm projecting a
single column out I'm selecting the int
column the in Scala I'm doing comparison
with one and this returns a boolean
result so if you look here notice this
shows the operations what we're
selecting was like a halt and its
yielding the name 64 that's the D type
of that column here our little is an in
date and then when we do the greater
than operation we load the boovie so the
point is we know a priori what the
operations are sorry what the data type
of the resulting
persons are well this doesn't look
exciting yet let's get a little more
exciting so here we're doing that we're
starting with the same computation on
the bottom here and then what we're
doing is we're selecting this out and
then we're doing the reduction we're
doing the sum at the top now the reason
this is interesting is because I can
then take this entire expression and
actually evaluate it at the same time so
this allows me to actually went on
iterating through this column to do the
filter first and then the sum at the end
okay I don't have to do multiple
operations increase intermediates and
temporaries I can do it kind of all at
once it allows me to do a lot of
optimization under the hood here's a
more complicated example this is no seat
belts okay so this is a little more
example of doing a joint I didn't show
the actual joint table on the right hand
side but this is at the base the same
operation it has a little bit of the
same operation in here it's a slightly
different example what I wanted to show
about this is we have complete control
over the syntax here now we're trying to
emulate pandas and it will come really
close we may even make it exactly the
same but there's some key differences
and these are the important points if
you'll notice in this group by
expression I'm using aggregate but after
that what I'm doing here is i'm doing a
key equals value pair now I could
actually make this work in pandas right
now but what I can't make work is the
very final point whereas they joined
valued at some that is it a deferred
expression if I did that in pandas right
now it would just it would probably work
but I wouldn't get the result I expect
here we are giving effectively an
instruction to the group I to aggregate
according to that column so I can defer
this operation so basically I this is
this
it's a compiler takes Python code here
this is a little example and we're gonna
turn this into sequel code we're gonna
take an integer add 10 x 10 point oh and
then round it we end up with an
sixty-four we've gone through a couple
of transformations we're gonna compile
this and get an actual sequel statement
so in the examples before I translated
the same code or the same not the exact
code here but the point is I can take my
code and I'm agnostic to my back-end I
can translate the pandas I can translate
to spark I can translate to bigquery
okay I can even mix these I could as an
example have one node which selects from
Park a another one which selects from a
CSV file and do things with them it
abstract this away from the user so we
just talked about the ibis layer it's
now I'm gonna talk about the arrow layer
arrow is just a back end here it's
nothing more complicated or different in
theory than like a sequel back-end so
arrow
you've probably there's a bit a couple
talks as I said in this conference arrow
is very fast
it supports zero copy protocols to and
from data frames it's very flexible
provides interim messaging and it's
actually widely supported by many
developers across many projects ok so
this makes this friendly again and I'm
not gonna go into too many details why
is this work well think of the data
frame on the top that's what we like our
data and we're going from traditional
role oriented storage to a columnar
format columnar format is great for
analytics you get Park column D types
you get optional compression on those
columns you can do much more importantly
you're normally just interested in a
certain subset of columns ok Pachi arrow
right now is there in a phase where
they're working on introducing
computation kernels so this is not just
a messaging format this is an actual
computation platform now it's not going
to be the entirety of pandas it will be
a general-purpose cross-language
computational platform
standard operations like mean and max
will be implemented things like that
casting and these will be generally
useful to pandas into other languages as
well okay so here's a little example of
what you can do once you know about
these so-called operator graphs and ibis
can just construct this and give it to
aro so take this little simple
computation here so we're taking a
vector a plus B we're taking the log of
that and then we're doing a reduction of
sum so the idea here is that and this is
completely transparent to the user this
is this is the nice thing about this we
can do parallelism here we can do
multi-core things we can do all kinds of
crazy stuff and you don't even know or
care this is a lot like the package that
we use currently called num expert we
can do things like eliminate temporaries
you know push down we can do a lot of
things here the point is it's going to
just work and it'll be transparent to
the user okay the one last thing I'm
going to talk about here is how do we
get there so up till now I really only
talked about the table abstraction or
the array abstraction a 1d or 2d
collection of arrays pandas is more than
that actually it has these nice concepts
of indices has a row index has column
labels this is a little bit odd sequel
does not have these concepts and so
they've proven very useful in pandas
actually indices are for a lot of
situations are useful but they can also
add some complexity so the Ibis and
arrow layer will be built upon an array
and a table abstraction without indices
this compatibility layer will add them
back the ID the goal here of course is
to make pandas compatible it won't be a
complete drop-in replacement but it'll
be pretty close so where are we now
arrow is a first-class project has been
actively developed especially over the
last year its format is pretty stable
and computation kernels are being you
know worked on everyday Ibis is actually
a fairly mature project at this point
and we are building additional backends
we had a fellow build the bigquery back
into three days it was not crazy pandas
to will basically compose these two
building blocks with a compatibility
layer on top what can everyone do well
we're at the num focus conference which
is great you're supporting them focus
pandas is a num focus sponsored project
we love you too for you to contribute
time or funds this is a big project as I
said this is like us you know replacing
the heart while while you're using it
I've always been a big fan of backwards
compatibility and we still will things
will break things will not work as
expected but I think we have a large
installed base and I think this means we
have a lot of beta testers out there
Thanks yeah I'll tweet the slides
they're there they're up here on
SlideShare and then that's my Twitter
handle any questions so the question was
why is arrow part of the SF why is it
Apache I don't know actually I a patch
is a very nice license actually it's
pretty it's pretty commonly used a lot
of folks pandas BSD but and probably
won't ever change the Apache
unfortunately
yeah well I think all the all those
little ton of projects now Apache so
that are uh yeah they almost all the
project have Python bindings spark as an
example has Python Bonnie's beam and
Lincoln airflow yeah maybe so this stack
is actually being worked on sort of
we'll call it both ends wes is
diligently working on arrow along with a
quite a number of folks and myself and
phil cloud who's a another developer are
working on sort of the top level of the
stack down it's kind of what's happening
we're trying to get both ends at the
same time okay so the question was will
the new pandas allow us to write UDF's
and be fast as well and this was exactly
my point
the answer is yes so the point is you
write an Ibis what happens is we can
then introspect the lambdas because
everything becomes a deferred expression
so we can actually in fact I was right
now will today do that rewriting of a
unwrapping and group by okay this is the
point we can do some optimization at
each level in other words at the top
level query plan level we can do some
optimizations and then as we pushed it
on the stack arrow will provide another
level of optimization in query planning
answer questions yeah yeah
so the question was what what are the
plan for users behind types an arrow and
the answer is they are supported arrow
is essentially a format which allows
arbitrary and custom metadata per type
so you can actually extend it without
running over these existing types if we
can move all the questions to the whole
way
[Applause]